Ohi tutto bene Guarda io sono super busy
in questo periodo mi sono giusto presa
due Day off per venire a trovare i miei
ma domani torno su In che senso parlo
Milanese Ma va sarà una tua impressione
come si sta al nord Guarda io su sto da
Dio sì non c'è il mare ma c'è il lavoro
[__] eh pensi sia stato facile per me
prendere tutto e andare a lavorare su
ogni tanto bisogna uscire dalla propria
comfort zone e pensare un po' out of the
Box ok A voi piace vivere qui però poi
vi lamentate che non trovate lavoro eh
non funziona così cara mia No non ho
ancora comprato casa ma tua idea di
quanto costi comprare una casa a Milano
A volte bisognerebbe un pochino
informato No siamo ancora sposati ma
stiamo bene così Chiama i figli poi ah
ah ah
[Musica]
adesso scusa ma una colla